you
[Music]
all right hello and welcome
to our career webinar
welcome to our career webinar how
today's
top companies recruit creating the ideal
resume and mindset for a technology job
in 2021 our
guest today is sarvajit malik co-founder
and the
chief business officer of the
organization for insta hire
i'm stuart creek i'm a marketing manager
here at
simply learn we're going to have a q a
discussion today and
i'd like to start by
giving you a little overview of the
webex instructions if you haven't used
webex before
you can enter questions for server g in
the q
a box please direct them to all
panelists so that everybody sees them
but
we will be collecting those and asking
those at the q a
section of the webinar toward the end
in the chat window today we'll be using
the chat window for our polls
which we normally run through the
polling function
and what i would like to do is uh
if you have a chat question again make
sure you direct it to host and presenter
or all panelists
so that everybody sees it and you send
i'm going to start with a poll and you
can put your response in the chat
how much work experience do you have
so if you would just enter a b
c or d in the chat window
and we'll give you about uh 20 seconds
to do that
that'll let sarvaji kind of scroll
through and get an idea of
what the numbers look like
a for most experienced and d for still
in school
five four three
two one seeing a lot of a
responses great so let's move on and i
will introduce sarvaji
um he as i said is the co-founder
and chief business officer of
organization for insta hire
he's responsible for anything that's
required to make customers happy
during customer interactions um
and he interfaces with
their hiring companies that work with
them
and keeps track of
the temperature of all of the
job seekers he previously founded a
company called trip hippie
and i think he has an interesting story
about that and
he is an alumnus of nit durga for an
engineering and has his mba from ntie
mumbai
so welcome sarbaji
and we can start our cameras
hey hi guys good to see you good to see
you all
so yeah uh brief introduction thank you
stuart
for introducing me um so
i am also an engineer like most of you
guys out here
and uh and also an mba it's like
like around 30 40 percent will be mba i
see a lot of guys
in college and a lot of guys in the
experience range
so uh briefly telling about myself
so i am a engineering graduate from uh
nit bulgapur
i passed out in 2009 and then i
did a job for around uh three years as a
consultant
in the manufacturing sector and then i
did my mba from nitty gritty bombay
uh post that uh after one and a half
years um
i worked with mahinda and then i
co-founded
trip hippy which was into adventure
travel it was the first of a coming day
adventure travel company in india and uh
post that i came into instagram and me
and alicia are
building a better future for millions of
candidates which are there
so as of now instagram in the
uh three years of making like when we
converted to the new platform
where we use technology to help
companies to hire better candidates
uh we our technology is like
pioneered in the way as in we only give
companies the best and relevant
candidates which are active at any point
of time
on our platforms we work with literally
most of the tech companies the operator
of india uh
last chapters like amazon walmart um
paypal vmware and then
we have very high growth companies
operating out of india like
uber shriki bookmark show and others and
we have a bunch of startups so
in total we work around with around 10
000 plus companies
and we have around 50 million candidates
registered on our platform
we started off with in the technology
role and then we diversified into
tech and non-tech both so this is a
brief about us
and we are going heavy on technology
and uh so in this session i will share
you some of the secrets
which we have learned through our three
and a half years of experience of
founding
and this will also help you to
understand uh
a uh what is required to make a resume
compelling to a recruiter
b what is the mindset of the candidate
which the recruiter or a company wants
okay so there are different sets of
companies different sets of recruiters
and uh as in in the indian scenario
recruiters are the gateway
where you get into companies okay so
first of all you have to make your
resume compelling so this is uh what our
session will be
and yeah over to stuart so yeah okay
um i think um i'd like to start with the
poll question you wanted to ask the
audience about
their general um motivation
um i think everybody's here because
they're either seeking a job
or thinking about seeking a job and so
again in the chat window if you would
tell us what
what's the reason the main motivation
that causes you to be looking for a job
now
again a money b uh looking for a new
experience
because you're bored see um
slightly different looking for new
challenges
and d to learn new things
in a new skill a lot of d
a lot of c a and d
okay so nobody's there for the money i
think like everybody's for new
experiences and
learning new things is it okay i'll give
it another about uh
10 seconds and then we'll move on
about five four three
two one
okay there we have it um
so you've got a feel for why people are
moving
or looking to move and what
what kind of recruiting process are they
going to encounter and what does it look
like
today um the process that companies use
for recruiting
so uh see the companies which
operate uh they operate on two basis
they hire under two purposes
uh first is to build something new okay
and the second is to scale something
which has already worked for them
okay so these are the two processes
which uh
help them to include so the first thing
is to build something new
uh so i go back a year back uh 2020 was
a landmark here
where we had uh corona coming in and the
pandemic
uh raging through and uh most of the
companies understood
that the talent which they source need
not be local
okay need not be coming to their offices
so the gamut of recruiting
increased multi-fold and the process of
recruiting changed drastically
okay so uh revelation has been that
it has completely changed how hiring
managers and
uh the ta heads view and shortlist and
reject the candidates
okay so now uh finding your developers
for
something new has become very common
okay as
for indian companies as well as for
foreign companies because the digital
content
or the digital consumption of india has
increased drastically
okay uh there you have one major
advantage is that you get motivated by
new set of problems which is coming in
okay rather than think of uh better
options where i can stay near the office
or on uh important the other important
things okay
so you get to work remotely you would
get to work on very interesting problems
okay so the interview uh type
has changed from person to video calls
the whole process has changed
so as the world adapts we have seen
multiple places
workplaces going remote so example
uber uber has been like a company which
has been working with us for the last uh
three and a half years three years
they have gone completely remote in
certain areas and they have got huge
amount of talent which is
which they could not access because they
had offices in certain places now they
can
okay so and this brings us to the most
important question
and uh stuart i will answer your
question like how do companies actually
assess these candidates
okay so uh companies looking to hire
people to build exciting stuff
the stuff which does not exist okay they
have to build it from scratch
they will look into your resume for the
projects you have built
okay so i have discussions with majority
of all the recruiters which are working
on our platform
uh like companies who are coming to
india like uh
gojek and two zeo and others okay slash
and others
they look for candidates who have very
good uh github repositories
okay how they actually contribute to the
community and
how they do open source projects so if
you are looking to get hired in
companies like these like even amazon
and uber
okay who are looking to hire developers
they
to build their new stuff be sure to
include these details
in your resume okay first thing they
will look into that
are you hands-on on that most of the
companies
in india look for hands-on talent unless
they are strictly looking for managerial
loans
okay so one key point is highlight your
projects
which helps other person understand your
work because i will tell you how the
process goes for the recruiter recruiter
will have
limited amount of time to look into your
resume and you have to highlight that
projects which you have done so that he
or she understands yes this guy is
important to the project
i have been handling or i have been
given the responsibility to hire for
okay so this is the first uh thing which
i want to tell you
highlight your projects and tell what
the project actually means do not get
into
technicals but tell them that this
project they have done
this is the users or this is what has
been the impact of that
yeah so this is the first thing which
you can do and
i get a lot of questions on this every
time i go to
our like chat center and candidate
center like
how am i uh like uh going to
get into such a big competition so the
first thing what you can do is
showcase your projects there will be
people who will be looking into a resume
for certain keywords certain projects
which you have done
okay uh
down uh okay so i'm speaking a little
bit
faster i guess yeah sorry so i will go i
will just slow down
okay uh second thing is
uh the second set of companies hire for
something
uh to help them scale something
so scale something means like they have
built the technology
now they want to scale it up to a
million users to 10 million users to 100
million users
example uh food delivery uh companies
like
uh students they majorly hire for skill
okay or to build uh they have their labs
which they built new technology apart
and they want to hire for skill so that
they can
implement this technology which is in
the lab to
the masses right okay so this is where
they will look for candidates who have
seen scale
okay they might not seen the nanima
scale
okay so magnanimous scale is not
possible for a candidate who have worked
in like
one year two years four years okay they
might be working for like 10 to 12 years
to see that
but scale can be identified how you
define
growth okay suppose you have taken a
company
uh so we worked on an architecture where
a company has been
doing one million transactions a year
and then you have scaled architecture
to around 10 million transactions a year
or build architecture
to support from like 10 to 15 sign ups a
day
to like 10 000 signups a day so this
kind of scale also
helps these companies to increase your
talent okay this
guy has done uh zero to one million or
one to ten million
maybe he can also do 10 to 100 billion
that risk they are
they are okay to take but if you have
not worked on scale
they might not shortlist your resume
okay
example uh suiji bintra uber
and a bunch of other new age startups
which are like hyper growth like
uh and uh there are bunch of other guys
who look for this kind of candidates who
have scaled their categories
or their product lines okay so
how do you stand out for such kind of
company
okay how do you stand up for such kind
of companies
you defined you built for scale and you
have to
specify that what is the scale you have
achieved
and why it succeeded and you have to
compress that in a
minimal number of sentences don't go
like a paragraph
an ideal resume should be a one-pager
okay so a one-pager resume should have
everything
so as of now you can see a bunch of uh
different type of resume
structures which are coming in okay with
all the graphics
and graphs which we'll be discussing in
the later part
but that also you can take but be sure
to compress
and you need a little bit of word
speaking in here so that you have to
get the recruiter i feel that yes i have
done this
okay and you should hire me for this
okay if i receive that leads that leads
to another uh
quick poll question i just want to share
with the audience to get
their what what their um
ideas are preconceptions are about
resumes
and and then
we can discuss
whether that's something that you
share or where they might be uh
where you might redirect them so in this
case uh
in the in the chat window uh tell us
what you think is most important
in your resume is it is it your
experience
your education uh your specific skills
or is it some type of attention grabbing
device that makes you stand out
and give you about another
15 seconds or so for that
do we'll close it in about five
four three two
one and
yeah most of it is c i think the skills
actually that is that is correct so uh
as we see uh
from uh our experience
uh skills matters a lot okay uh
we have seen how pedigree also matters
in some cases like
uh guys from iits and niti is another
colleges and b schools coming in and we
have seen the skills matter a lot
when you talk to people okay who have
built or scale companies
you will see they hire for skills and
aptitude only
okay even skills is the secondary thing
they have for aptitude
because if the guy has attitude to learn
and understand and take up a new skill
they can learn the skill easily but if
the guy is not
able to grasp new skill they won't
become they won't be a very good asset
for that company
so yes c is important but before that
aptitude is also very important to
like grab those skills and use it on a
day-to-day basis
okay that's a that's an interesting
point it's it's not
um you're talking about aptitude isn't
as in the
the ability and willingness to
take on a new skill or learn a new area
yeah
yeah adapt and own adoption that is the
motto here so adapt you adapt to a new
skill and own that new skill
and then you learn a lot of things about
it
so uh that we have seen in uh like a lot
of companies
even even in the in the sense of uh when
we work with a lot of
recruiters our insights from this
interviews which we had with like we had
around uh around 34 000 to 45 000
recruiters
every day accessing our platform and we
do a lot of both questions and
we have our customer services team talk
to them
so we wanted to understand uh for for
the candidates itself
to help them get better jobs and get a
better life
for if they do if they hire for multiple
job positions
and uh but what are the key pointers
which they see in resumes that stand out
okay so around 48 percent
say that we see who have worked in
similar companies
okay if i'm hiring for an e-commerce
company i will see guys who have
worked in certain e-commerce companies
okay if i'm hiring for a certain company
which has
uh this kind of scale i will see people
who have worked in this kind of school
so around 48 percent out of this
uh 45 40 000 recruiters told us this
okay uh then what we see in the
in the resume is numbers which has been
put up to support the skill and and if
they are explaining what
the numbers actually mean to them okay
and the technologies which they have
worked for
so that is around 70 72 percent that is
a huge number
because they will only need people who
work in certain kind of technologies
or have experience in like hands-on
experience in working in that
and also if they have scaled in this
kind of technology
third is uh who have given
like their github or big bucket links
and
have very high activity on them okay
so this is one thing that we have seen
that a lot of uh
social um uh proof is required so
uh i uh we we work with a lot of very
very high hyper growth startups
very hyper companies also which is uh
operating out of india and build their
uh
development offices and other offices in
india
they say that uh our first qualifier is
how the candidate has solved larger
problems for the community
okay and how they're contributing back
to the community so
if you see coding coding is a community
exercise like people do and then they
share their code
and people come and collaborate so this
is how they see
how this guy can collaborate as a team
solve large problems
um a question
that is slightly related to what we've
talked about in the poll but what
what do most job seekers overlook
or or fail to do when they're putting
their resume together what's
what are some of the biggest mistakes
they make
so the biggest uh mistake they make is
they uh talk about things like
so everyone wants to talk about their
experiences right so when they talk
about experiences they go
like i have done this and i have done
that but they fail to
mention it in very solid points okay
and when you don't mention it so see a
recruiter will
look in an average day a recruiter looks
around
500 to 700 resumes average on an average
day
okay on a day when he has multiple job
openings to post and to look into
resumes the
time goes less okay so like 30 40
seconds
you have 30 40 seconds to impress a guy
it's like an elevator pitch
you go to elevator you talk to a guy and
then you have to like boom
you have to get into it okay so how do
you do it
okay the first thing what guys miss is
they they
will put on paragraphs and then huge
paragraphs
that is like first thing the recruiter
will see a paragraph
they might go to the resume and see
bullet points
okay they do not highlight things okay
suppose i have scaled from 1 million to
10 million
they should highlight that thing right
so whenever
this guy is looking suppose a fintech
company is looking into
your resume and you see that one to 10
million transactions
is highlighted so then the bug will go
on
then they will come and say okay this
guy has done 1 to 10 million
the other guy might have done 10 to 100
million but he has not highlighted
secondly the projects the projects which
one
showcases that should have the impact
okay what is the impact of the project
so
you know people will try to tell about
what makes the project all about how to
accomplish that but what is the impact
okay
if i have gained some cost savings or
have reduced the development time
or have eased the pain of thousands of
customers
okay so this is one major thing which
people
normally they do not uh like they
neglect
so in mba so all of you guys who are
there if someone
is an mba so you guys already know that
in the top b school
you have uh around one month to prepare
a resume
okay so in one month you are trained to
prepare a
polished resume and it's a one-pager
resume whatever your experience is
it should be a one-pager so all your
experiences you should be able to
explain in one page
okay right now you can also go for two
pages but that the perfect thing is a
one-pager regimen
okay so that that that things like
how can you compress information but
showcase the most important information
on top
humans generally read from left to right
so how you are you developing your left
panel
of your resume and don't keep in plank
you develop your left panel so that
people when read
they will read from left to right okay
so yeah sample retrievers you will get a
lot of sample resumes
the understanding of creating a resume
is like a storyboard
you have to tell a story and you have to
tell a story within certain seconds
so your story has to be very very strong
now there are 10 000 other guys who is
looking for a job same job as you
it will all come to the three four lines
or the five six lines which you have
written
to support your claim so that you should
work upon
so it's the storyboarding which
candidates generally falter
they write a lot of things and they make
it a three-page or four-page resume
thinking that
they will get selected but no it should
be a one-pager at the minimal
like the maximum length should be a one
pager and people should
write everything in that one page so
that the recruiter has also a time
when they will open the page they will
look into the whole resume at one glance
you will highlight certain points what
you want to highlight about yourself
yeah i i want to hit on what you said
about the left panel
and when you're you're creating the
points that the resin that the recruiter
is going to see
it sounds like what you're saying is
that your sentences
should start with the important
experience and the important
accomplishment
of that so that the first words they see
when they come across the line
are you know scaled to
10 million for a company rather than
doing it the other way around where they
have to wait
the end exactly because they may not get
to the end of the sentence
i like what you said about elevator push
for it for the audience an
elevator pitch uh imagine you you get on
an elevator in a building
and you recognize the boss who's who you
want to hire you
and he hits floor number 12
and you have the time from the ground
floor to floor number 12
to talk to him about why he should hire
you so
an elevator pitch for anything is
how would you compress it down into that
you know 30 seconds or 60 seconds
that you have available
the more um the more
concise you can be the better you are
exactly exactly um and the process of of
this uh like this whole process is kind
of a sales process if you understand
so if the candidate is selling the
credentials to the recruiter
the recruiter buys it and now the
recruiter will sell the candy rate uh
not sell the candy literally but sell
the contents of the candy so this is a
good candidate
the hiring manager should have a look at
it so how will the recruiter pitch that
candidate so it's all about the pitching
so recruiter will pitch the candidate to
the hiring manager hiring manager will
like the candidate
and then again they will pitch to the
senior level where they get a job and
all that
so the company is also pitching to the
candidate why you should join me
and the candidate is pitching that why
you should take me
so this is all about the pitching and
the elevator pitch which you have
like told in detail to the candidates
yes
yep um what do you think cyberg makes
the biggest difference
between someone who gets hired and
someone who doesn't get hired
when they're both applying for the same
job
so uh the first thing is the content
which the candidate has
uh written on the resume okay so i have
seen
very very good candidates very good
candidates like these guys have worked
in
excellent projects getting rejected why
because the resume was not at
par okay so what what was the
like thing which they have faltered so
there are three basic
things which you can make a resume
compelling okay
so use graphics use graphics to
highlight your best skills
okay don't mention skills which you are
halfway
because if you are asked questions in
the first call that
okay you know java so tell me about this
about java and you don't know
you're gone right so that is the first
thing like the recruiter will call you
for a
ten minute call to understand what you
know and then if
they get something which is not correct
and which is not
in line they will reject you okay so
don't mention anything which is half bit
you tell them okay i have a novice in
this i am learning this and i will learn
in
one year two years but i know this very
well so highlight your best skills
so if you are getting hired you are
getting hired on the skills which you
already know
and you are not getting hired on the
skills which you are in the learning
phase
because if suppose i am hiring for my
company
and i am getting a developer so or a
sales guy i will not hire a sales guy
who is
learning to sell and before that he has
been in other
other jobs okay so i might as well
i will hire a friend and train him uh
like to do things right
so this is how you go about it but
aptitude yes
uh company sees aptitude that can be
like through tests and aptitude tests
which the company throws it
second is um a company also sees
the intent of the candidates so what is
the intent of the candidate
there are like online courses offline
courses
which the candidate can take on a free
time
to like increase her grasp
of knowledge or to enter into another
field i have seen
a lot of people asking me that um how do
i get into cloud computing how do i get
into data science
that is how you get into things like you
start learning there is a
single point of to learn you cannot
leave your job at some point of time
there might be financial troubles
leaving your job and going to
a new college to do that but you have to
start learning
so you take courses the their online
courses which you can do
so this also is taking into
consideration a recruiter will
always see what is the intent of the
candidate is he or she a learner
and if he or she is learning
continuously and continuously
improvement
so continuous improvement is the intent
which the recruiter will always look
into
so always be ready to put on your
courses which you have done
and what did you learn from this courses
have you implemented that knowledge
okay third thing is very important
right now we are all in a remote setup
and right now
you see companies building teams
and these teams are built on a single
person or couple of person
who lead these teams so that they can
scale up that product
okay but so you won't hire for see
you want so if you see if you have uh
guys have read uh books about uh like
scaling up tatters and
there's a very good book by you often
which is a blue screening
which you have seen so a company has
different stages
so it's very small stage like five ten
percent company then it goes to ten two
hundred then goes to thousand
people company so these guys they will
look for people who have leadership
skills
okay though they might not be so much
skilled
but they might have leadership skills
and aptitude to grasp that thing and to
lead a team
so these are two different aspects we
should look for leadership abilities
how will you judge the negotiability if
i have to build a team i have to find a
leader
then that leader will build a team for
me okay so
if they're working for like thousands of
teams i cannot hire thousands and two
thousand hundred people for the team
i will have a thousand people they will
hire the rest hundred for their things
right so the leadership ability so most
people
mention extracurricular activities as if
they wanted to have a section for that
and they just write down the
extracurricular activities what
leadership abilities and qualities do
you want to project to the recruiter
that is the most important thing what
kind of committees you have been to
okay what are the activities you have
taken while in college or school
okay and you have to give them solid
evidence of that
so generally people uh like write
true things but don't fake it in this
case like if they find out that will be
a very bad experience
and one of the most important factor
which
i have seen across through like we work
with around uh
15 to 20 million candidates okay the
first
uh certain things which we have seen
stands out
in most candidates from the others is
like eq the emotional quotient
okay so asking yourself uh what is this
and why is this important
okay how will you perform in a team how
will you lead a team
how will you align yourself to the
mission of the company
recruiters always like candidates who
are
very enthusiastic and curious so when
you are going for interviews or you know
preparing a resume
have that energy and showcase that
energy you should be energetic and you
should be excited about the opportunity
okay how will you align yourself so this
is how uh
they will see your positions of
responsibility they look for ngos if you
have done any work
in organization in your college you have
led so all these things come into play
um before we forget uh can you
mention the name of the book the title
and author of the book that you
mentioned
about uh scaling so reid hoffman he's
the founder of linkedin
uh so blitzkailing
what's the title again it is blitz
scaling b-l-i-t-z
yeah which scaling
terrible title because blitz and and
scaling both
one ends when it starts with the same
letters or sound
so it runs together but anyway there it
is in the chat window
um and i'm gonna
ask a poll question because it relates
to what you were talking
about in terms of extra
curricular activities leadership uh
demonstrating that that ongoing
curiosity and that type of thing so
yeah let's uh do our last poll
here
and what what do you in the audience
think is the most
important for landing a job is it your
qualifications
is it your attitude and your mindset or
do you think both
are equally important
and again we'll give you about another
20 seconds to
answer in the chat window
most of them are seen
and five four
three two one
so there you go um and so
my question about that is that you know
what's your opinion on that service
sheet and and how does the right
mindset set the a successful job seeker
apart
yeah so a very famous quote uh by a
renowned argentinian economist
he his name is fred kaufman he told that
doing your job might be hazardous to
your career
okay doing your job is might be
hazardous to a career
so this is a one-liner with encompasses
everything like
first thing is what is the mindset the
candidate is bringing and what is
the energy so so every team which we
have
has a certain energy level okay when you
add extra energy to it it goes up
so everyone wants to add new energy
levels to the team
to raise the bar of energy plus the
performance
so the biggest factor which you see
in most cases is the mindset of the com
candidate
okay so it consists of various factors
which you see on day-to-day life
you might like you might not consciously
like tick mark okay this
this is mindset a mindset b but you can
specifically understand
first thing is how does she handle
situations
how does she take ownership of the
situation so you will see certain cases
somebody takes full ownership of the
situation and solves it
as if it is her problem okay it's not a
company's problem it's a problem
that is the that is the ownership level
mindset which we have
what makes from a internal position to a
senior level position to a leadership
position
okay that is the single most thing the
mindset so
if you see uh recruiters they always
look for
leaders okay so they might be looking
for an entry level guy
but they will always look for leaders in
that okay because they
will always think that okay if the
leader is the best bet which they can
get
okay so uh if you see that your resume
speaks volume about
how you handle people many resumes will
speak about
a lot of positions and positions of
responsibility
okay so uh the most important question
is
why is mindset such an important thing
so this can be answered in one short
question are you willing to go all the
way
okay so but are you willing to go all
the way so how
like mindset creates opportunities as a
person okay
uh so you will see a lot of like one
good friend of mine amite
okay who comes up with like
extraordinary skills and experience
very good pedigree very good college and
then
uh after that campus placement and they
got a very good job
but he faces like he he thinks the job
is job
so what happened is after certain point
of time his
growth stopped and he is still stuck in
the mid seminal level
other other guys who in the same batch
has went up so you will see a lot of
examples like that
why because it is the mindset
okay so mindset is you are leading
yourself and then you are leading a team
you might not be leading a team at entry
level or like till mid senior level
or like junior level but you are leading
yourself and
as you lead yourself you will be leading
that your team will follow
okay you people will look up to you this
guy
is leading themselves and this is how
you get into
so you might be an entry level guy in a
large organization
but a sense of ownership makes a lot of
difference and the whole difference like
believe me this is quite visible in in
companies which you go to
just going to say uh i think
i i would like to ask one last question
um
what are the most important steps that
you recommend the people in our audience
to take
uh to prepare their job search this year
in 2021
okay so this is uh completely by
personal opinion and should be taken
with a pinch of
salt uh the most important uh thing is
first of all you take a piece of paper
and pen and write down what you want to
do
okay why do you want to get into a job
okay first things first
okay things which you should be there in
your list
should be kind of a storytelling
approach which you should do a
storyboarding approach
okay don't start typing on your resume
like
in one go think about what the things
you want to project
talk to your peers okay talk to people
who are not in your
segment like if you if you are a
marketing guy talk to a guy who is in
sales
or who is a developer and see how they
see yourself
so you you ah you will be able to pitch
to them
okay in very simple lines that what you
stand for and why
you should be hired okay so that is the
first
uh level of authentication which you
should do
okay so when you have this paper and you
express yourself
then go to the resume and present
yourself
okay so then the resume becomes your
storyboard to the world so this is the
one picture
the recruiter will never see you okay
they will never see you till you come to
uh in person or video calls before that
thousands of candidates are getting
rejected or they are not
uh replied back why because they
they are not presenting a very
interesting story
to the recruiter okay so
make a solid resume divide into three
parts preferably make it a single pager
okay you can have multiple resumes for
different set of companies to highlight
your competencies
so certain companies you might have
worked in different segments
and you might have different
competencies okay but you can make a
different set of resumes for different
companies
to apply for this very common practice
in many of the
b schools okay introduction should be
that
with a two-liner it shows your past
experience don't
write people writing about your past
experiences and in college so
make it a little bit of like 2-3 liner
which
helps you to uh like helps other guys
understand yeah this is the guy who
stands for
so this is just a trailer and then your
experience in notable
uh extracurricular activities remember
nobody wants to see what uh what
like your experience has been if they do
not see any value in them
so present the volume such a way that
becomes compelling to them
okay most important thing which we
is also networking networking is a very
important aspect
you do not network with people when you
need a job you network
it it's like every day every day every
year day in the year you should start
networking so this is the practice which
you should do
in india it's quite neglected uh certain
people do
network very well and more like eighty
percent of the guys people do do not
network
so start networking this will help you
do two things first is whenever
you want to switch you have the full
knowledge of the company
or you have full a bunch of peers in
that company
which know you and they can refer you
second is
you get to understand what the market is
doing okay what what is the
new technologies coming in what is the
new marketing strategies which are being
implemented
what they have done so this all helps
you to gain more knowledge about the
market about the businesses
which are operating okay yeah
so the third thing is uh create a very
compelling profile over job boards
uh select a good uh photograph okay with
a clear background
okay we have like people also create the
first impression when you
when they see you over uh like
networking sites and also over the job
board
with uh like different set of
photographs make it very professional so
see all the uh like with a clear
background that will help
and um like how
you operate and how you network will
also help you to understand how you can
add value to this company so you will
have a first-hand data on that
okay excellent um we're just about at
the time for questions and answers i did
want to mention one thing
from our conversation here i noticed you
used terms like elevator pitch and
trailer and storyboarding so
those are familiar to me because i one
of the things i do in my spare time is
make movies
for our audience a storyboard is
is how a movie maker tells the story on
paper
like a comic book like in panels
that show what will be on the screen and
it's a great way to summarize
the important points of the story and
how they what sequence they fall in
um and that applies to resumes as well
as
what's your personal story you're
telling to
the recruiter and what sequence does
that fall in what are the the main
scenes or highlights that you want to
put in front of them in the in the right
sequence to persuade them
to pass you up the chain to
the hiring process right so at this
point
i'm going to go to the uh various
questions we've received i've been only
be able to
to ask you a few of them in the time
allotted i apologize the audience in
advance for that
but um come with some of the
key ones uh we have uh one that came out
of the webex chat
from ishika who asks uh does this
this does distance learning education
um right on the same level as
regular campus courses okay
so uh see uh if you
if i take you back like five years from
now ten years from now distance learning
was a new thing in india
okay and the campus courses were given
much more importance than
distance learning at this point of time
when people are hiring for aptitude and
skills
distance learning becomes a little bit
gained a little bit
importance throughout this five to six
years down the line okay
so yes a campus courses will be supposed
will
have a weighing of like 80s to 30
but distance courses are also getting
their importance as
as in the next
yeah and and of course on-campus
learning is
not available you know right now so
we're all even the people who are
enrolled yeah yeah
everything is business learning so right
now like when we
talk to a lot of people when you talk to
a lot of recruiters you get to know the
ground reality
so distance learning or no distance
learning people also
learn from youtube okay people learn to
code from youtube people learn to
market and do marketing like social
media marketing from youtube
and they're earning so it is not like i
will do business courses and this is my
degree and i
will i get a job or don't know you if
you have the skills if you can perform
in the assignments which you have been
given
or you have the projects which to show
for and you have the clients which you
talk to
so they will talk to your clients and
say hey this guy works really well
and you should take him so we will be
hired so people are looking for skills
they do not
really care about your courses which you
have taken so yeah
um ajaz asks uh if you can
give a list of the skills that are most
in demand in the market now that you're
in priority
so in demand skills in the technology
side will be
anything related to machine learning and
ai python
and like devops is also coming up okay
and other skills are also there uh in
the uh
non-technological side you see social
media marketing
digital marketing uh seo all these
things are coming up
so anything online anything digital
because if you see
uh the the corona pandemic which
happened
in like for march everything has been
shut down this has
increased india's consumption of digital
uh
content like multi-folds it's like we
are ten years forward
okay so right now you see a lot of uh
people only transacting
so if you shop keepers in india they
only transact mostly transact on
internet okay paytm and all these apps
coming up
so how do you market these
things to the other guys you do it by
digitally right
so people are there is jio in india
which has given us
a free internet almost free internet so
this is how you market it so this is the
skill which is coming up most
social media marketing product marketing
and marketing over
internet and digital channels
okay um we have a couple questions about
skills like rpa and cloud computing and
and
i presume that those are also um
yes like robotic process automation has
always been there
so it is always in demand okay so
automation will always be there
and people are automating things uh
cloud computing yes
it's definitely in demand okay there are
large companies who
are hiring for a lot of cloud computing
engineers and
at this entry level as well as senior
level guys
who are operating out of india yeah are
there any particular
industries that are um
more um that are looking
more strongly for digital skills at this
point because of uh
you know not having them in the past or
is it pretty much across the board so
it's pretty much across the board
because if you don't have a digital
presence you are don't worry
okay so if you see if you if you see the
small shopkeepers also they will they
are also on google
and they want you to rate uh them as
in google okay so please rate me five
stars on google so that i can get the
next set of customers
okay so it's across and there are
companies which are coming up new
companies who are coming up who are only
pushing for digital
first so mobile apps are there there are
thousands of mobile apps which are
released
if you see uh the influencers the
one one major uh testament to the
digital consumption is
the rise of the influencer uh content
marketing or
marketing in india is like the
influencers they earn in
millions in india three years back
they were nowhere right now they are
running in millions how because of
everything like social media marketing
and companies are hiring
influencers so digital skills uh social
media skills
are invoked so yes if you are a good guy
if you can create content if you see on
twitter and instagram people are
creating content and they are earning
money so yes
thank you for that by the way
we've seen a little bit of backlash
against in in the united states
against influencers who um
you know some of them take it too far
and assume that
they can get whatever they want for free
by just saying i'm an
influencer um but the real ones who
actually do have you know followings of
many many hundreds of thousands of
people um
have a have a big impact um we have
several questions from people with uh
mba qualifications some some newer and
some with uh
you know 25 years of experience and
they're curious to know
um what uh
path should they take into learning
digital skills what are the things that
are most important for them
to learn and um how can how can that
advance their career see uh for mbes
your digital skills
will uh there are several buckets which
you can fall into
the first is uh if if you are doing in
marketing
or if you are doing in uh uh like
analytics okay so these three two three
buckets which you fall
into if you're doing in marketing it
will give you a lot of leverage when you
have social media marketing skills
okay so if you can uh understand how
people
consume content and you can push the
right set of content
you get inbound traffic for your company
or for your uh
startup or or for your venture okay for
a person who has
like 10 to 15 years of experience 20
years of experience
okay they can also learn this skill so
there is no point there is no age where
you can stop to
like stop learning okay you can learn
the skills you can apply
might be you you are a better influencer
or
a better social media marketer than a
new age guy
because you know you can tell better
stories so it's all about story making
it's
it's all about stories so if a guy with
a 20-year experience can
tell better stories and they can project
that story
to the customers they will have a better
uh like
they will have a better job they will
have more in like
customers following them clients
following them that is how
uh we can go about it yep
thank you um i think for the last
questions uh
i'm going to ask one from aditya i think
it applies
to a number of people situations but
the question is i'm a mechanical
engineer working in an automotive
component
manufacturing company for nine years
but for the last two years i'm
supporting ai
operations through upskilling so
can a person like that
trans
uh shift into the ai and machine
learning field
and definitely definitely that is not a
let's see
to learn uh skills like this you can you
can
use your laptop in your free time and
you can start coding
so it's all it's all how you how you uh
it's all about your attitude like you're
a mechanical engineer you will
understand things so you will have an
aptitude for mathematics
okay right like i'm assuming your
mechanical injury will understand
uh thermodynamics and like you will have
applications for mathematics
so you use this mathematical skills to
understand uh
things like python and our whatever
skills you need to learn
and this is all like very simple to
learn it's not very very difficult to
learn
if you want to get into that you will
have to put in some effort and then you
can go
get into that so that is not a problem
and as as of now you you're not
constrained for data
the data is freely available you can
open a youtube channel and
start like to understand what like
machine learning actually is and how you
can like
see your career like two years down the
line in machine learning
rather than going into mechanical i am
an electrical engineer i'm like
uh shifted my team to uh
management and then right now i'm the
founder of a tech company
you can also do it yeah it's
especially for people with an
engineering background who understand
how systems work and how
things are built
usually makes it a lot easier for them
to understand
exactly the intricacies of software
engineering and
coding and building systems out of
software components so um i i wanted to
to to end by asking you about
trip hippie um can you tell can you tell
us just in a minute or two about
yeah that's what happened yeah so after
passing out from mba so
uh three of my friends two from my mba
days and from my engineering days one
so we were having trekkers so we used to
trek a lot and hike a lot
so one day we got lost when we were
trekking into
in maharashtra in the state of
maharashtra and then
an idea came in like see there are
thousands of trekkers and adventure
enthusiasts so why don't we build a
community for them
so we started building a community for
them and then they asked for
how can i go here and do uh trekking or
raffling or rafting or kayaking or
paragraphing
and then we build a vendor uh website
like vendor listings for them where they
can book
and take the tours from listed verified
vendors
so that they don't end up in trouble and
they have they are in safe hands
so this is how we did it and uh one and
a half years we ran it and we scaled it
with like uh around one thousand plus
vendors were there
and we organized around ten thousand
twenty tools this is how we did it but
it's a wonderful story about
how like you said earlier
extracurricular activity
it turns into a major turning point in
your career so
yes um so i want to um
say thank you uh sergey for being here
and um got your linkedin information up
here
for uh people if they would like to
reach out to you
um it's been a really wonderful
conversation
and um i look forward to
to keeping in touch with you in the
future um
thank you goodbye uh thank you audience
uh
for like uh getting well thank you so
much thank you so much guys so you will
get a sample regime i will answer all
your questions you can just
ping me on my linkedin id so i will
answer all your questions if you have
any
and thank you simply learn for uh
hosting me
it was been a great pleasure to talk to
you guys and like talk to around
uh one thousand of the participants
which were there today attending the
conference yes
if you send me links to the sample
resume and any other
types of resources um i will include
those in the follow-up email to the
audience so everybody can get that
um yeah and i do want to mention um
that as sort of as you said
continuous learning lifelong learning is
important um there's a lot of resources
available
and one is skill up from simply learn
which is a free service we offer
allows you to self-study in several
hundred
in-demand skills mainly in the digital
economy area and
i think we've dropped the link into the
chat window a few times but i will do
that again before
we close the session um and again it's
uh it's all free and it gives you
um entries into the the kinds of things
that sarvajut was talking about
um we do have another webinar coming up
one week from today
um this one is specifically in the data
science
area with one of our
data science advisors
ronald van loon he will be talking about
which career data scientist or data
engineer
might be a better fit for you if you're
looking to enter that field
and so we hope to see some of you there
and please do keep in touch with us
through our social media channels simply
learn
on facebook and twitter and
on linkedin so thank you all for being
here thank you sarvajit again for
for joining um and this concludes our
webinar
um like i said i will drop one more uh
message into the chat window and then we
will be
ending the session so thank you all
thank you guys
you